[Musique]
allez tourisme et horizontaux la même à
la ville on la barre de tri la part
d'autres et c'est un mal qui touche
saint-tropez à la fin des années 50
il changera jamais le fil h varois le
monsieur du sexe masculin peu bedonnant
arrive de mort d'une chambre et puis de
secondes après demande où est la
madrague de brigitte bardot troisième
derrière j'ai rien contre elle parce que
les charmantes
il aura suffi d'un film et dieu créa la
femme de roger vadim en 56 pour que
saint tropez de dien le fief de la jet
set des milliers de touristes à la
poursuite de leur idole viennent à
l'heure autour du port sous les yeux des
villageoises impuissant mais tout arrive
et les regards d'hommes il faut furieux
là les attend avec impatience c'est
parce qu'ils nous portent un peu de
pognon
et puis nous fonderie en car même au
fond il faut dire ce qui est le début de
la mue pour cent tropez dans les années
50 c'était un petit port de pêche de
5000 habitants
apprécié des peintres et des
plaisanciers
[Musique]
une décennie les stars leurs fans et des
fortunes du monde entier s'y sont
agglutinés résultats dans les années 70
c'est le début d'une frénésie
immobilière sera ici la poche qu'il est
petit et vous voyez l'avant nous avons
quand même eu quelques arbres quelque
chose qui nous permet de respirer de
vivre convenablement mais je parle on
parle de faire de nouvelles routes font
écho à m
la municipalité a du mal à gérer la
situation elle tente de préserver ces
espaces naturels mais ces moyens ne lui
permettent pas totalement de résister au
développement urbanistique chez l'homme
moderne les choux pour acheter tout ce
gâchis
je veux bien essayer mais je n'ai pas
dans les années 80 le mouvement
s'accélère les étranger rachète tout les
rares hôtels les appartements en ville
à tel point qu'en 2006 peu de tropéziens
d'origine arrive à rester sur place
bcg un une fatalité peut-être mais saint
tropez échappe à la bétonisation en
dehors du centre des villes ont été
construites mais de nombreux espaces
sont encore préservés en ville en
revanche les petits commerces ont été
dévorés par les boutiques de luxe et les
prix ont explosé entre 4500 et 26 mille
euros le mètre carré
j'ai eu un sentiment oui d'être d'être
d'être chassé un petit peu de saint
tropez et ne pas pouvoir rester là où je
suis né là où je travaille
c'était un gros pincement au coeur
saint tropez compte 4299 habitants selon
le dernier recensement
pendant la saison celle qui avant l'été
quand petit port de pêche accueillent
chaque été trente mille visiteurs par
jour
[Musique]